it's out with the old heathers
heather why can't we talk to different
kinds of people
gently with the chainsaw and in with the
new
veronica heather chandler is looking for
you paramount network
released the first trailer for the
highly anticipated heather's tv remake
and thankfully it includes the movie's
best line
[ __ ] me gently with a chainsaw from
heather chandler
shut up heather yeah shut up heather
heather only i tell heather shut up oh
yeah
to heather duke originally played by
shannon doherty
sorry heather there's already a dirty
old bag in that seat
and we are loving this new heather
mcnamara oh god
i just thought of something oh heather i
really doubt it things appear to be
shaping up nicely before the comedy
series premieres in 2018.
after dropping the teaser the cast
stepped out in unison
for sunday's mtv video music awards
i am so excited to go to the vmas oh my
god
is this really happening is this
happening and we all look fabulous
you guys are gonna love the show i
cannot wait